Okay, well first of all, I want to thank you
for being here today for this interview.
Do you prefer Mr. The Grey or Mr. The White?
I have both set of robes, I go by both names.
You can call me either.
Great.
Well, welcome.
I come back to you now, at the turn of the
tide.
That's... great.
Okay, so I'm sure that you've heard about
our YouTube channel, CinemaSins, and its great
success on YouTube.
Many of those words have no meaning to me.
Maybe Middle Earth is a little further behind
in technology than I thought.
You know what?
It's not that big of a deal.
It's really not.
Okay, let's just dive into the questions.
Alright?
Okay.
First of all, are you a homosexual?
Hmm.
That is an oddly specific thing to ask.
You don't want to start with something less
personal?
I'll ask the questions around here.
Okay.
So, are you gay?
No I am not.
I'm sad to say a powerful elf queen holds
the keys to my heart.
Galadirel?
She's a total bitch.
Ice queen is more like it.
Indeed.
But I still want to see what's underneath
those robes, don't you?
That is truly disgusting.
Alright.
So... you're sure you're not gay?
I am sure, yes.
You never experimented in college or on any
of your many all-male quests?
Are all your questions going to be about my
sexuality?
Yes.
Master human, may I inquire why you are so
fascinated on this subject?
Well, we—I wrote this song.
And it's about you.
And I want to make a music video for it, so
I wanted to get you to be in it.
But I need to be gay to be in it?
Well no you don't have to be.
It'd probably make things a little easier.
Have you thought about asking Ian McKellen.
He played me in the Regular Earth movies and
he's actually gay.
Yeah.
Well, we wanted to use the real thing.
But only if the real thing is actually gay.
Well, no.
I mean...
Listen, you don't have to be gay.
You could just pretend to be gay.
Or temporarily gay, like Anne Heche.
Let me ask you this: let's say there's nothing
but dudes left on Earth.
Middle Earth or Regular Earth?
Either.
Alright?
Okay.
All the chicks are dead.
Well, Galadriel can't die, she can only go
to the undying lands.
Will you stop—then she's there, alright?
Will you stop nitpicking my scenario.
The point is, you're horny, you got a boner,
nothing but dudes.
Would you ever...
Hmm.
Consider
No.
Maybe.
Nope.
No?
No.
Not even if you were in prison?
No prison can hold me.
You have only broken out of prisons with the
help of eagles.
You didn't do any of that on your own.
What?!
The only time I've known you to break out
of a prison is because the eagles are helping
you.
Well, that doesn't mean that you know everything.
Do you want to be in the video, earn some
cash, or not?
If I say no will you still send me back to
Middle Earth?
Man, I'm not planning to send you back either
way.
Then how am I supposed to get back?
F*ck if I know, dude.
You're the wizard.
Isn't there a wardrobe you can go walk through
or something?
That's Narnia, sir, a completely different
fantasy series.
Completely
It's not completely different.
Okay similar.
But I still—I don't need to go to Narnia.
I need to go to Middle Earth.
Maybe you can take the wardrobe to Narnia
and then catch a bus from there to Middle
Earth.
There's no bus from Narnia to Middle Earth,
alright?
Are you gonna tell me how to get home?
How did you even get me here in the first
place?
Alright.
Alright
How did you get me here?
How am I here?
If I knew that I would be the wizard.
Hmm.
Well, what am I supposed to do?
I would probably recommend getting a job.
Job.
You know, food, shelter, all that sh*t costs
money here in Regular Earth.
I know of a job, actually.
Co-star of a music video.
I'm not going to be in your music video, confound
it.
Now point me toward Middle Earth and I'll
be on my way.
Hmm?
Now!
I cannot believe you made me hit him over
the head.
Relax, he'll be fine.
And what are you gonna do when he wakes up?
He will eventually come to grips with the
fact that he's stuck here in our world.
Then, he'll do the video just so he can have
the cash to pay for some food.
I'm pretty sure this still counts as kidnapping.
You can't kidnap a fictional character.